Abdo leah has always been able to take
clean tap water for granted
that's why she's angry that her local
community candelita has recently sold
the public water system so far she's
never heard anything positive about
water privatization I would add them or
locate they made other mundo we're all
afraid it will get more expensive that
the company will make profits which
should actually remain within our
community with the people of Canada
later 5,000 people live in come to later
a small Castilian town in central Spain
they collected 4,000 signatures against
the community's plans to sell outcome
the latest water but their protests went
unheeded the plans had already been
finalized the community's public water
supply was sold for 700 thousand euros
these companies want to make money at
all costs even if they have to cut back
on quality and don't make as many
repairs or checkups if they don't have
to they simply won't do it he didn't get
a handle but I'm a little why nothing
there's no shortage of fresh water in
candelita it comes from a mountain
stream and it's quality is renowned far
beyond the town itself maintaining the
water pipes is expensive the community
can't afford the necessary investments
so local authorities are counting on the
financial might and know-how of private
companies la empresa we turn to a
company for help because our
infrastructure is outdated and weak
email us
he broke apart a pair oh and we also
want to make better use of the water not
just for private households we want to
use it to boost tourism and agriculture
and bring candelita out of the crisis y
para potency are lagana Beria yadagiri
filter ax
in Spain where water is especially
precious in the heat more than half the
population gets its water from private
companies more and more communities are
privatizing their water services it's
the big sell out Peter
Yoho is considered an international
expert on water markets
he says the economic crisis in Spain is
what's behind the rapid change in
ownership within the water sector well
that is you know Theodore's it's not
that's what the financial sector is
converting that crisis which actually
provoked into new business opportunities
in Luca field well we can put pressure
on debt ridden communities to sell their
property or simply anything else to
survive these dire financial
difficulties Nestle platform financier
Esther mandated of it well the real
estate bubble be followed by a water
bubble in art a show in Galicia the
bubble has popped the city's water
supply was privatized years ago prices
were going to be raised by one-third but
the citizens fought back we pay enough
already and the water should be cleaner
some days it's really dirty guy bath
let's get rid of muscles here I admit it
but I think it's to let them sometimes
it looks more like chocolate than water
in the system breaks down water gets
lost very bad
we defiantly the community pulled the
plug and backed out of the contract it
argued that the water supplier hadn't
done its homework only 3 million euros
had been invested into the ailing
infrastructure instead of the agreed 11
million euros Lobby that Kathina it was
shocking that the company refused to
invest even after it had raised the
prices by 30% during our talks it became
clear that they needed the money just to
be able to continue the water suppliers
shouldn't be run like that we now
believe that Artesia's water supply
needs to be 100 percent public del agua
en pour thean Paulo
the water provider in question has now
filed for bankruptcy and has declined to
comment publicly it's the same company
that the community of kondal ADA has
sold its water supply to 100% Abdul Lia
is convinced the town will deeply regret
this step in the long run they sold it
for 30 years plenty of time for the
company to do just what it wants but
Kunda leaders residents are planning to
take legal action they're invoking an
agreement whereby the community has the
final say regarding its water supply but
it's like David versus Goliath
in Spain large corporations are in the
lead when it comes to the fight for
water